six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go next to our caller from the
eight four five area code caller from
eight four five go ahead hey this is
Mark hey Mark go ahead all right as a
what's called the first one's gonna be a
quickie roaming millennial is actually
Asian what do you but my Asian oh sorry
she's uh actually mixed no I think about
it but at some point you've identified
the race of someone but what's the
what's the context of relevance of that
oh sorry about that that's my bed and
you commented you commented once about
the talking to a white supremacist or
something along those lines
yeah I will from what I saw it so I
thought that roaming millennial who I
might be on a panel where that politican
was a white nationalist but I've since
been told she's not but you know you can
be Asian and a white Nash and advocate
for white nationalism anyway okay but my
actual question is actually um how do
you research something that that is kind
of like this conspiracies and not kind
of get pulled in is much is that is my
actual question because I listen to
really really good economists but the
things they believe like the Hillary
Clinton stuff and the powers besides
those yeah besides those you know crazy
conspiracies like those they're very
accurate on things that are happening uh
economic okay but wait a second hold on
a second mark let me see if I'm a how
card what a really good economist that
believes that 9/11 was an inside job or
whatever one of them is rogue news they
used to be called rogue money the
podcast another one is for the
economists well he goes by the pseudonym
of be the gorilla so economists Eve the
gorilla believes in 9/11 conspiracies
but on economics he's really good is
that what you're saying yeah like he's
very confident at what he like he's very
confident but add that but the stuff he
believes is questionable at best and I
don't feel like looking into it because
I don't want to get pulled into you know
that kind of madness and Oberon simply
took a real lot of things who's another
really good economist that believes
conspiracy theories in other areas
another one is and I don't not I don't
know their names be fair but here their
channel their YouTube channels the
shotgun economics and there's another
one oh look I think the LaRouche PAC as
well
oh no so let you gotta get that that the
stuff will rot your brain okay so the
LaRouche what's the guy's name it's I
forget the guys first name
well is it Lyndon LaRouche yeah listen
yeah you can very I promise you mark you
can very easily find good economists who
don't go by names like Steve the gorilla
and don't also believe 9/11 conspiracy
theories and then you won't even have
this problem of having to figure out
they sound so smart about economics but
they think 9/11 was an inside job you
can find a class accurate right they're
relatively accurate I linked to a lot of
people other than them it's just that
they're one of the accurate ones when it
comes to certain factors in the economy
and nothing that person what you can
find left-wing economists like Richard
Wolff you can find right-wing economists
like Thomas Sowell they're not gonna
touch 9/11 conspiracy they're not going
to touch new world or like there's just
lots of people I don't think you need to
deal with Steve the gorilla for economic
advice mark I prefer to call thank you
so much great to hear from you great to
hear from you